now we've come to the end of it this
video concludes my reviews of the Holy
Trinity of Nicolas Cage 90s action
movies that would be the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit has been fun I'm not
gonna live I've enjoyed revisiting these
so let's do
[Music]
welcome to Conair so Connor was a
Nicholas Cage action movie came out June
I believe it was 2nd 1997 so Connor
actually came out before face off still
that was the summer of Cage the premise
of Connor is so ridiculous
yet so amazing when I saw the trailer I
was like this is gonna be the greatest
movie ever there's a prison plane
transporting a bunch of prisoners
described as housing the worst of the
worst we're talking Cyrus the virus
diamond dog Billy bedlam Garlin Green
Nicholas Cage's accent just loud your
cage and we're admiring this movie's
cage the Nic Cage that was stupid I'm
cutting that out when Nicholas Cage
plays Cameron Poe he's just a dude who
got into a bar fight and then he kills
this guy defending him and his wife and
so he goes to prison so he's a parolee
hitching a ride home on this plane
housing the worst of the worst what
could go wrong yeah the prisoners take
the plane but Nicolas Cage is like I'm a
good guy I'm gonna save the [ __ ] day
that's for the cast there's so much
cashed in his movie I mean Nicolas Cage
became a bonafide action star he went
from the science geek in the rock and he
was like all right now I'm gonna duel
another thing but you got to give it to
the dude he just commits in this role I
hear he did a lot of his own stunts John
Cusack because also he's just this
likable dude who's he's the good guy of
the good guys
you know you got the bad guys and then
you have dicks Comenius one of them I
mean this was Miles O'Brien this [ __ ]
blew my mind Miles O'Brien dick so
anyhow John Cusack in this movie had me
from a little ruckus movie was actually
my introduction to Dave Chappelle I've
not seen Dave Chappelle before he was
pinball and Conair also I just read this
I don't know how true it is but I heard
he ad-libs some lines or a lot of his
lines in this movie regardless the
scenes he's in he's not in it for long
but when he is in it he does stand out
he does steel the scenes
man it smells like someone's [ __ ] in
your mouth told me you loved me get out
of my face and if we're talking about
those 90s villains that I always gush
about John Malkovich and Conair he's one
of them talk about taking a ridiculous
movie in a ridiculous role in a
ridiculous movie and just owning it and
there's something about John Malkovich's
voice that already he sounds like a
psycho doesn't he always kind of talks
like this he has this monotone voice and
there's something about it that just
seems a little off I just love him as
sighs actually like everything when
they're in the plane so here we go the
movie always starts to slow down for me
and I'm like I wouldn't say it loses me
but it's not as interesting when they're
not on the plane when they touch down on
the ground the plane gets stuck sure
there are explosions upon explosions not
that it's not fun it's probably because
of the soundtrack that electric guitar I
mean when that thing kicks on after
Nicolas Cage is like oh I'll show you
good does exude do get shot in the arm
and keeps going man what a boss it's
your barbecue and it tastes good this is
the uneasy dynamic of everyone thinking
on Nicolas Cage is one of us he's one of
the bad guys in it kay just like I'm
totally not I'm trying to find a way to
screw these guys over and so the
authorities can capture them that's
where it's most interesting for me this
movie does make you have to take leaps I
mean leaps upon leaps I'm not just
talking about the end which I'll get
there in a second when they go to Cyrus
Grissom's old cell and Jiri bricked the
wall and we're all his notes in there
and a bomb there was a bomb who smuggled
a die hard with a vengeance explosive
device up one of their orifices to get
it to Cyrus Grissom in prison how did
that get there
that is the worst security maximum
security ever but even when they find
out that all of the guards are actually
cons and someone's like those guards
aren't guards they're constant you want
this one guy to go stop these armed cons
these are just convicts you're sending
him up to Cyrus the virus alone to stall
him you just sent
man to his death that's what that was oh
shoot steve buscemi ak I got to talk
about Steve Buscemi because dude just
it's perfect perfect casting again I
hear that they wrote the role for Steve
Buscemi makes complete sense so having
him as this Hannibal Lecter type serial
killer who's actually the only one who
has philosophical fought I mean of
anyone in this movie who talks at all
garland green seems the most mentally
put together but we all know he's
completely not now you're talking
semantics funny enough garland green
doesn't really do much in the movie he's
just he's there he's there to be weird
but he's just there but that aside if he
wasn't in Connor Connor wouldn't be as
enjoyable because his insanity just it
works for this movie those things that
just feel out of place in this movie
that scene where garland green sits down
with the little girl he's hanging out
with her that always did
I suppose the scene seems out of place
for me because the setting seems out of
place like it was a scene that they
filmed after the movie was over they
were like oh we want to see him with
garland green doing something all right
here we'll film a pickup because they're
out in this little airport this airfield
in the middle of nowhere seemingly in
the middle of nowhere and then in the
middle of nowhere boom there's this
little trailer park so it's weirdly out
of place as this scene seems I do like
the fact that it starts getting
introspective on garland Greene's own
perception of his mind
you're lucky I am safe
you can't Marisa there is no medicine
for what I have regardless my mom saw
Conair on TV and they cut the scene
where the girl flakes could buy out so
the TV version is actually much darker
than the actual theatrical version but
yeah let's talk about the end so the end
they crash in on the Vegas strip which
is cool it's awesome actually crashed
into a casino that was just there were
like aw we're gonna demolish this casino
look wait can we crash a plane into it
for a movie please but there's this
whole chase for Cameron pogos after sigh
prison when I watched it recently I was
like you're done dude you're home leave
this to the police then again he did
threaten casey po so you know this tom
is personal but after that Cyrus the
virus goes flying through this dis
overpass bridge and then lands into this
construction zone not just a
construction zone it's like some evil
conveyor belt smashing things it's like
at the bottom of this thing you're gonna
find jowenko the lava beast well it goes
from Vegas Strip to definitely not Vegas
strip in the end Connors ridiculous has
a hundred and one holes in it but it
does have fun for it it's still a 90s
movie that knows what it is of the Holy
Trinity and nomine Patri fili a spin it
to Sunday of Nicolas Cage action movies
it's probably the bottom of the three
but doesn't make it bad I mean it's bad
but good but still bad but good it has a
strong villain a hero with a solid moral
code it's fun enough for me to say
whenever I watch this movie I always
have a good time no alcohol required
right now I'd like to think the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by Ray Khan ray Khan is no stranger
to this channel in terms of sponsorship
once again I appreciate their support
and they're the slick stylish true
wireless earbuds have started about half
the price of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and give you some
solid sound their everyday e25 earbuds
offer six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass in a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit and as always they
come in a variety of fun colors and
Raycom earbuds are both stylish and
discreet they have no dangling wires or
stems and as always personal experience
here they always stay in place have yet
to fall out of my head also incoming
hair comments and for all reasons listed
they remain my favorite workout earbud
because also personal experience those
quarantine snacks seemed a good idea at
the time in the boards of the Great
Saruman I have looked to do so click the
link below in the description get
yourself 15% off your order and thank
you once again to rake on for sponsoring
this video I do appreciate it and write
us for Connor or the Holy Trinity of Nic
Cage movies in general what's your
favorite whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more ran out of breath click right
here to say more
[Music]